how did commander keen come to be
so the design process
we would start from we had some idea of
what we wanted to do we wanted to do a
mario like game it was going to be a
side scroller i was going to use the
technology we we had some sense of what
it would have to look like because of
the limitations of this adaptive tile
refresh technology it had to have fields
of relatively constant tiles you
couldn't just paint up a background and
then move that around i the early design
or all the design for commander keen
really came from tom hall where
he was uh you know he was kind of the
main creative mind for the the early id
software stuff where we had an
interesting division of things where tom
was all creative in design i was all
programming john romero was an
interesting bridge where he was both a
very good programmer and also a very
good designer and artist and kind of
straddled between the areas but
commander keen was very much tom hall's
baby and uh he came up with all the
design and backstory for the different
things of kind of a
mad scientist little kid with i am you
know building a a rocket ship and a zap
gun and uh visiting alien worlds and
doing all this that the background that
we lay the game inside of and there's
not a whole lot to any of these things
you know design for us was always just
what we needed to do to make the game
that was going to be so much fun to play
and we made our we laid out our first
trilogy of games you know the shareware
formula is going to be three pieces we
make entertain one two and three and we
just really started
uh busting on all that work and it went
together really quickly it was like
three months or something that while we
were still making games every month for
uh for gamer's edge we were sharing
technology between that i'd write a
bunch of code for this and we'd just
kind of use it for both
again not a particularly good idea there
that had consequences for us
but
in three months we got our first our
first game out and all of a sudden it
was three times as successful as the
most successful thing apogee had had
before and we were making like thirty
thousand dollars a month
immediately from the commander keen
stuff
and that was again a surprise to us it
was more than we thought that was gonna
uh that that was gonna make and we said
well we're gonna certainly roll into
another set of titles from this and in
that three months i had come up with a
much better way of doing the scrolling
technology that was not the adaptive
tile refresh which in some ways was even
simpler and these things
so many of the great ideas of technology
are things that are back of the envelope
designs i make this comment about modern
machine learning where all the things
that are really important practically in
the last decade are each of them fits on
the back of an envelope there are these
simple little things they're not
super dense hard to understand
technologies and so the the second
scrolling trick was just a matter of
like okay we know we've got this 64k
window
and the question was always like well
you could make a two by two but you
can't go
off the edge
uh but i finally asked well what
actually happens if you just go off the
edge if you take your start and you say
it's like okay i can move over i'm
scrolling i can move over i can move
down i'm scrolling i get to what should
be the bottom of the memory window it's
like well what if i just keep going and
i say i'm going to start at i you know
what happens if i start at fffe at the
very end of the the 64k block and it
turns out
it just wraps back around to the top of
the block and i'm like oh well this
makes everything easy you can just
scroll the screen everywhere and all you
have to draw is just one new line of
tiles which everything you expose it
might be unaligned off various parts of
the
of the screen memory but it just works
that no longer had the problem of you
had to have fields of the similar colors
because you doesn't matter what you're
doing you could be having a completely
unique world and you're just drawing the
new strip as it comes on but it might be
like you said unaligned so it can be all
over the place and it turns out it
doesn't matter i would have two page
flipped screens as long as they didn't
overlap they moved in series through
this uh two-dimensional window of
graphics and that was one of those like
well this is so simple this just i this
just works it's faster i'm there it
seemed like there was no downside funny
thing was i it turned out after we
shipped titles with this there were what
they called uh super vga cards the cards
that would allow higher resolutions and
i and different features that the
standard ones didn't
and on some of those cards
uh this was a weird compatibility quirk
again because nobody thought this was
not what it was designed to do and some
of those cards had more memory they had
more than just 256k and four planes they
had 512k or a megabyte and on some of
those cards
i scroll my window down and then it goes
into uninitialized memory that actually
exists there rather than wrapping back
around at the top
and
then i was in the tough position of do i
have to track every single one of these
and it was a mad house back then with
there were 20 different video card
vendors with all slightly different
implementations of their non-standard
functionality so either i needed to
natively program all of the the vga
cards there to
map in that memory and keep scrolling
down through all of that or i kind of
punted and took the easy solution of
when you finally did run to the edge of
the screen i accepted a hitch and just
copied the whole screen up there so
on some of those
uh those cards it was a compatibility
mode in the normal ones when it all
worked fine everything was just
beautifully smooth but if you had one of
those cards where it did not wrap the
way i wanted it to you'd be scrolling
around scrolling around and then
eventually you'd have a little hitch
where 200 milliseconds or something that
was not super smooth as it froze a
little bit and this is the binary thing
is that one of the standard screens
there's one of the weird ones the super
vga ones yeah okay and so we would
default to and i think that was one of
those that changed over the kind of
course of deployment where early on we
would have a normal mode and then you
would have you would enable the
compatibility flag if your screen did
this crazy flickery thing when you got
to a certain point in the game uh and
then later i think it probably got
enabled by default as just more and more
of the cards i kind of did not do
exactly the right thing and that's the
two-edged sword of doing unconventional
things with technology where you can
find something that nobody thought about
doing that kind of scrolling trick when
they set up those cards uh but the fact
that nobody thought that was the primary
reason when i was relying on that then i
wound up being broken on some of the
later cards
you